defying a lockdown and a curfew
protesters attack a bank in the capital
Beirut the value of their money is
decreasing at an alarming rate and on
Monday their anger at the central bank's
policies and at a political class they
accused of corruption and mismanagement
erupted in a wave of violence across the
country demonstrators in Tripoli in
northern Lebanon blocked roads and
fought with police officers responded by
firing rubber-coated steel bullets which
injured protesters soldier I swear
please stand with us it's too much we
stand by you but they are killing us we
can't afford anything anymore we are
starving
I sold my fishing boat for pennies
enough is enough for 15 days the dollar
keeps going up and down I have a
daughter in hospital she needs an
operation and it's Ramadan Lebanon's
currency has been depreciating for weeks
but in the past few days the liras lost
at least 60% of its value on the black
market the government is hinting that
the central bank could be intentionally
engineering the collapse as the country
struggles with a lack of hard currency
and its worst economic crisis in decades
the central bank is either incapable
absent or directly instigating the
dramatic drop those in power say there's
an attempt to topple the government by
sabotaging financial stability
opposition politicians who are backing
the long-serving governor Riyadh Salameh
believed the ruling alliance led by
Hezbollah is trying to take control of
the central bank which implements US
sanctions against the Iranian backed
group mr. selami
is perceived as an American ally inside
Lebanon that does not mean that mr.
selami is not responsible and his
monetary policy was the right one but
definitely we're facing a coup
money transfer offices and banks no
longer dispersed dollars and people are
deprived of much of their savings due to
informal capital controls
the crisis is seen as a struggle between
those who hold financial power and those
who have political power and it's
putting Lebanon's stability at risk
Victoria Gaytan B al-jazeera